لقد نشأت أنا وبروك على الكثير
من نفس القيم منذ صغر سنّي ، لقد
أثار والداي إعجابي بالقيم التي
تعمل بجد من أجل ما تريده في الحياة
والتي تعمل بجد من أجل ما تريده في الحياة
وأن كلمتك هي رابطك  افعل
ما تقوله أنك ستفعل أن
كلمتك هي رباطك وأنك تفعل ما
تقوله وتفي بوعدك بأن تعامل
الناس بكرامة واحترام حتى لو
كنت لا تعرفهم وحتى إذا كنت
لا تتفق معهم  لهم أن تعامل
الناس باحترام وأنا شرعت
في بناء حياة مسترشدة بهذه القيم
في الماضي تصل إلى الجيل التالي
ونحن بحاجة إلى نقل هذه الدروس
إلى العديد من الأجيال لمتابعة
لأننا نريد أطفالنا وجميع الأطفال
تعرف هذه الأمة لأننا نريد
أن يعرف أبناؤنا في هذه الأمة أن
الحد الوحيد لارتفاع
إنجازاتك هو بلوغ
أحلامك واستعدادك للعمل الجاد من
أجلهم ، وأن الحد الوحيد
لإنجازاتك هو قوتك.
الدكتور
eams واستعدادك للعمل معهم